or the provisional tally for The
Crossings to this point in this year is
still slightly lower than it was last
year at this time when the number was
slightly over 13
000 now as you mentioned there 13 Boats
were detected crossing the channel by
some rough calculation that would mean
yesterday about 53 people per boat and
when you think about the type of a bow
that's found discarded alongside the
Kent Coast these are normally rubber
dinghies they're not very big they're
not very spacious you can really imagine
that those migrants traveled and very
crammed conditions and that's not just
uncomfortable it's also very dangerous
the English Channel is one of the
busiest shipping lanes in the world it
often has treacherous unpredictable
weather however when the weather is nice
like yesterday that is when the
Smugglers really try to take advantage
and they cram as many people as we as
they can on those boats now you'd think
that one of those reasons why she's in
other Prime Ministers stopping the boats
as one of the Central Key pledges of his
policies is to avoid the repeat of last
year when the record number of people
crossed the English Channel was over 45
000 people but it's fair to say that up
to now certainly his policies and his
promises haven't been that successful
the central policy by the Home Secretary
said about ratherman to send migrants to
Rwanda well that was defeated on appeal
now the government has lodged a bit to
try to take that to the Supreme Court
the highest court in the land but we're
certainly still a long way from any
decision there now the home office says
that they've simply can't cope with a
high number of arrivals they place an
unprecedented pressure on the Asylum
system they say but what the Charities
are saying is that these are people
fleeing persecution they're playing Wars
and that there should be a better way to
try to deal with them once they get here